[APPLAUSE]
JIM MEEHAN: Thank you all
so much for coming.
Thanks to John Henry,
as David said.
He has sponsored our cocktail
today with El Buho Mezcal,
which I'll be demonstrating
in just a sec.
And I've been nagging John for
about a year, politely, of
course, because I knew that if
he knew David, and I'd hope to
come and speak to you guys.
In many ways, I am here
because of you.
And I'm not sure if
you know that.
And part of what I'd like to
happen during this Google Talk
is to open up a dialogue
about not only-- you
want me over here?
Don't forget your cocktail.
[LAUGHTER]
JIM MEEHAN: I'd like this Google
Talk to eventually
become a dialogue, because I
think that not only am I here
because of what you guys are
doing, but I think that the
future of what I do depends on
the sort of work that you do.
And I'm not sure what brought
you here today.
I imagine a cocktail might help,
maybe a book would help.
I don't know if David mentioned,
but we've brought
PDT hats, t-shirts--
we have El Buho t-shirts--
and all of the books that I have
on stage on my demo table
over there are going to be given
out to one of you for
asking a question after
I stop rambling.
So I don't know why you came,
but hopefully, for whatever
reason you're here, you
will be rewarded.
But what I'd like to do today
are a few things.
First I'd like to demo the
drink that I made.
It's a perfect drink for Cinco
de Mayo, which is coming up in
just four days.
So I figured for those of you
who came out to maybe learn a
thing or two about mixing
drinks, I could show you how
easy it is to make the
drink you're having.
And next I'd like to talk
about the book I wrote.
It came out in November 2011,
"The PDT Cocktail Book." But I
want to take a bit of a
different spin, I want to
actually talk about the process
that I used to come up
with this book.
A lot of times people, they'll
come up to me and ask me, so
you wrote a cocktail book,
what was it like?
What made you want to
write this book?
And I think that it's really
hard to write something new or
to create something new when
you don't know what's come
before you.
So I'd like to talk about the
process that I used to develop
"The PDT Cocktail Book" and I'd
like to introduce a big
idea that I'll throw in the
beginning, that I'd like you
guys to marinate on as the
Mezcal floods into your veins.
And maybe we'll talk about
it together in
about half an hour.
But as I said before, I believe
that the internet,
Google, YouTube, Wikipedia, on
and on, and on his change the
way we learn, it's changed
the way we searched.
My generation--
I'm 36, I'll be 37 this year--
was one of the last generations
that went to the
library, when we needed
to find something out.
The last time I went to the
library I felt like I needed a
master's degree to learn
how to use it.
The internet is a lot easier
to use than the library.
But one of the things I found,
as a kid, when I used to go to
the library, before I used the
internet to find information,
was, when I looked something up
in a card catalog and found
out where the shelf was to find
it, on my walk to the
shelf I'd oftentimes pass books,
all sorts of different
books-- books about ship people
tying knots, or guns of
the early Civil War, or just
books that were very
interesting to me.
And I found that not only in
what I'm going to talk about
with "The PDT Cocktail Book",
but in how kids and my
generation is searching these
days, that in many ways what I
learned along my searches, was
just as interesting as what I
was going to get.
And one of the things that is
confounding, ironic, maybe
sad, is that when we Google
something, or when we search
for something on the internet,
it takes us exactly to what we
are looking for usually, and it
doesn't allow us to go on
that journey along the way and
see other things that might
interest us.
So why don't we get to
this drink before I
exhaust that topic.
In thinking of Cinco de Mayo,
the Margarita is obviously the
cocktail that is most
on our mind.
In creating a new cocktail--
which I guess you could call
this a new cocktail--
I often take a classic
cocktail--
the Margarita--
and play around with it.
The Margarita--
tequila, lime juice, Triple
Sec, Cuantro.
I usually use a little agave
nectar to sweeten it, to
balance it out.
So I took that and I played
around with it.
I'm going to use El Buho Mezcal,
I'm going to use
fresh-squeezed lime juice, a
little bit of agave nectar--
I usually lengthen it into a
syrup so it pours easier--
and then a couple twists.
And these are things that you
probably will see if you go to
cocktail bars in New York, like
Mayahuel, which features
agave cocktails in
the East Village.
But you've found that your drink
from five-six years ago
has gone from maybe
a delicious sour--
something like a Sidecar
or Cosmopolitan--
something that is strong--
it's actually good drinks--
sweet and sour, and then
people are adding bitters
to their cocktails now.
And then later people were
adding Saint Germain and Creme
de Violette and floral
ingredients.
Then people were adding herbs
and herbal liqueurs, like
Chartreuse, and adding
that herbal quality.
And then, finally, people have
started adding spice and hot
things, so this is
a Hellfire Shrub.
So taking that original recipe,
I'm going to take a
shishito pepper, which
isn't generally hot.
They say that a few of them
in each batch is hot.
I'm going to add half
an ounce of--
a little bit less, because
this isn't a syrup--
add that on top of
the shishito.
I'm going to give
that a muddle.
And what I did for your
cocktail-- which is in that
giant camera over there-- was
I put all this on top into a
large bin and just muddled
that, just like
you're seeing here.
I'm going to add an ounce of
freshly-squeezed lime juice.
And then I'm going to add 2
ounces of El Buho Mezcal.
And you'll notice that when
I'm making this cocktail,
because I'm speaking, I
haven't added any ice.
I'm a big proponent when you're
making cocktails,
especially, when you're making
cocktails at a bar like mine,
where I might be making three
or four cocktails at a time.
Build your cocktails without any
ice and let them sit, so I
could make four of these
if I wanted.
And then as soon as you're
ready, then that's when you
want to ice your shaker
and shake.
And, John, I don't actually
have a glass up here.
So this allows me an opportunity
for John, my handy
barback to come and
bring me a glass.
I'm going to add my ice
on the other side.
John Henry, El Buho Mezcal,
thank you very much.
Give it up.
It takes a village, everybody,
it takes a village.
So I'm going to get
that together.
You want to get a nice
strong seal there.
I always seal the
cocktail shaker.
You want to seal right here,
so that it's easy to open.
If you put the cocktail shaker
straight in, you're going to
have a hard time
getting it out.
Give it a nice hard shake.
[SHAKING COCKTAIL]
If you go to a cocktail bar, and
they're not shaking very
hard, order a beer and a
Maker's on the rocks.
Strain that.
You can fine strain it, if you
don't want all the little
seeds there.
And that's it.
This is the cocktail, if I were
serving it at home, I
could put a salt rim on it, I
could add some Chile to the
salt and make it a
little colorful.
I could add citrus zest.
I could add all sorts of
stuff and maybe only
do salt on the side.
You could add a shishito pepper
there if you wanted.
You could garnish it
with a lime wheel.
What do you guys think?
Refreshing?
For some of you, it might
be a little too sour.
be a little too strong.
For some of you, it might
be a little too sweet.
One of the things that a lot
of people of my credentials
maybe don't mention is
that's OK, we all
have different tastes.
So the beauty of--
I feel like-- every
recipe is modular.
So if it's too sweet, pull back
a little on the agave; if
it's too strong, pull back on
the Mezcal, and on and on.
So that's your cocktail.
Does anyone have any left?
Man, all right.
Because I wanted to make sure
that we weren't getting in the
way of efficiency here
at Google today.
And I wanted to get you, guys,
a good buzz before I started
on my journey.
Now, as I said, part of what I
want to talk about is not only
the book that I wrote, but
the journey that I
went on to write it.
I first started working at the
Pegu Club on Houston Street
with Audrey Saunders in 2005.
Audrey Saunders was
Dale DeGroff's--
Dale DeGroff was her mentor.
She worked with him right when
he was leaving the Rainbow
Room; was the head bartender at
Dale's bar that was opened
called Blackbird.
When Blackbird closed, Dale
brought in Audrey as the head
bartender at Bemelmans.
Audrey ran Bemelmans for many
years and then opened the Pegu
Club in 2005.
And for me, this is very much a
watershed moment in New York
cocktail history.
I got to be on the
opening bar team.
At that time it's hard to
imagine, because there are
dozens and dozens of great
cocktail bars, even in
Brooklyn, much less
Manhattan now.
But at that time, the cocktail
bars in New York were really
Milk & Honey, Flatiron Lounge,
Angel's Share--
those were the main ones.
Basically, there was three or
four bars Employees Only was
almost open, and Little Branch
was almost open.
So there were five great
cocktail places.
Audrey opens the Pegu Club, and
it was really sort of a
coming out party for
the cocktail.
In these years 2005, 2006,
2007, you really see the
cocktail bar and the cocktail
bartender go from person to
person to person, to place to
place to place, till the last
couple years, where three places
are begetting nine
places, and nine places are
begetting 18 places.
So we're seeing an exponential
growth.
But at the Pegu Club Audrey--
and still to this day-- had a
collection of vintage cocktail
books behind the bar.
And at the time I was interested
in cocktail books.
I had Dale DeGroff's "The Craft
of the Cocktail." I had
Gary Reagan's "The Joy of
Mixology", which you'll see.
I had Ted Haigh's "Vintage
Spirits and Forgotten
Cocktails", which you'll
see in my presentation.
But I really wasn't aware
of how many old books
that were out there.
And Audrey had original copies
of the 1862 Jerry Thomas, of
the 1948 "Fine Art of Mixing
Drinks" by David Embury.
She had the 1937 "Gentleman's
Companion" by Charles H. Baker
and all these beautiful books
for us to look at.
And I immediately realized that
there's so much about the
history of bartending, and so
much about what I was doing
for her there that I really
wasn't aware of, and I wanted
to investigate more.
I went to eBay and started
spending all of my tips on old
bar books and started meeting
people who had
more of these books.
I'm going to forward
to my first slide.
1862, Jerry Thomas.
This is the first "Bartender's
Guide".
The book on the left, the one
that's sort of old brown one,
that is the first edition.
The green book on the right
is the 1876 edition.
And the book in the middle
with the torn cover--
so these are all my copies; they
would have weighed about
70 pounds, or I would
have brought them--
is the 1923 edition with an
introduction by Herbert Asbury.
This is a book that came out
and was printed many times.
You can see the price here,
I think it's says $2.50.
I think it initially started
at $1.25 and then went to
$2.00, and then $2.50.
Each of these books was printed
probably in seven or
eight editions.
And in the early days,
this "Bartender's
Guide" was very simple.
It was a collection
of recipes.
The recipes were not umbrella
recipes, like cocktails are,
they were separated into shrubs,
into punches, into
scuffers, into negoos,
into sours.
Cocktails were very
categorical.
And this was a very simple
utilitarian book, that was
obviously meant for bartenders
that had in the 1862 addition
a big appendix that was filled
with information for bar
owners for how to make your own
cordials, how to make your
own bitters.
This was before spirits were
distributed in bottles.
So it had information for how
to tap kegs of beer, and how
to blend whiskeys together.
Very utilitarian, extremely
influential and it spunned
what I'm going to call
"Jerry's kids."
You can see the 1876 edition of
the "Bartender's Guide", on
your left you see O.H. Byron's
"Modern Bartender's Guide" and
C. F. Lawlor's "The
Mixicologist." "Modern
Bartender", 1884, the Jerry
Thomas in the middle is 1876,
"The Mixicologist"
on the right, I
believe, is around 1891-95.
There are going to be cocktail
geeks on YouTube, who are
sitting there scolding me for
not knowing my dates, so I'm
just going to make sure and
check my cheat sheet, which
I've created here.
See, yeah, you've got 1894
Byron and 1895 Lawlor.
And what I call these "Jerry's
kids", these are other
bartenders from other places.
I believe O.H. Byron is New
York, and "The Mixicologist"
was published in Cincinnati.
But these are books that have
very similar gatherings of
recipes, some differences--
you know, we've
gone another 15 years.
But the "Bartender's Guide"
really hasn't sort of
transformed itself
as a genre yet.
It's still a collection of
recipes with a back appendix
that includes information about
mixing your own syrups
and bitters, and cordials.
Moving on to about 10 years
later, we get the first what
I'm going to call "technical bar
manuals." 1900, the book
on the bottom, Harry Johnson's
"Bartender's Manual." And
then, I believe, the first
editions of the Hoffman House
were published around 1894,
this one's around 1912.
And you can see the picture of
the guy dashing the bitters,
and the slide says, this is
how you dash a bitter.
One of the reasons why am I
showing you these slides, one
of the things that I was
thinking about when I was
writing the "PDT Cocktail Book"
is how, why write a
cocktail book, unless you're
going to add something new.
And then what is already
out there, what has
already been written?
And as I started looking through
these old books, it
was interesting to find how,
through each generation, you
sort of saw an evolution, even
in the books themselves.
The 1862, the 1890s, things are
sort of very formulaic,
they haven't really
evolved yet.
And then in 1900 to around 1910
you see books like these.
These are 300 to 400 page
manuals that tell you how to
write a guest check, how to
hire a porter, how to keep
your walk-in clean; the most
infinitesimal details were all
mentioned in these books.
And I thought it was incredibly
interesting,
because we are right now at a
time, where if I pitched a
book to a major New York
publisher saying, you know I
want to write a book, and I want
to make sure that there's
a good 20 pages on how to get
the bathrooms cleaned
properly, how to make sure the
garbage gets collected, how to
make sure you know how to hire
a bartender, how to hire a
barback from Mexico and not get
busted by the government.
I want to make sure
and add that in.
The publisher would look at me
and be like, uh, this is
totally disinteresting
and just pass it off.
If you look back 110 years,
there weren't many, but there
were at least a handful of
these books that were
published and republished, and
popular, because I can still
get my hands on them now for a
lot of money, which is showing
that during this time bartending
is moving into a
craft, is moving into
a valued profession.
People want to read these books,
and the craft of the
cocktail is evolving.
We move forward from there.
This on the left is Kappler,
1895, he bartended at a very
posh hotel called the Holland
House. "Jack's
Manual", that's 1907.
Dave Wondrich shall be
disappointed, but I don't
remember where Jack worked.
And then on the right is
1908, William Boothby.
I actually have, I think,
I have Boothby up
here to give away.
And I have Mr. Johnson up
there to give away.
These are what I'm calling
"the first celebrity bar
books." And as I said before,
we've moved from very sort of
simple recipe books to very
involved professional guides,
to right around 1910, we see
these bartenders who've gone
from just being guys who ran
pubs to being famous.
Many of these bartenders at the
time had travelled around
the country, they had mixed
drinks in numerous posh
hotels, and by now they have not
only their own books, but
they have books that they're not
calling "The Bartender's
Manual" or "How to Mix Drinks",
but they're calling
it "Jack's Manual", or they're
calling it "The World Drinks
and How to Mix Them" and they
got that weird sort of thing
with Boothby, where he is
the standard authority.
But the bartenders kind of by
1910 become a celebrity.
Moving forward to vest pocket
books, which for me, remind me
of the function that PDA sort
of serve for bartenders now.
A lot of times now if you go
to a cocktail bar, and the
bartender doesn't know the
recipe, the first thing
everyone does is they grab their
phone and they start
Googling, well, I can
find the recipe.
And everyone is on their phone
Googling the recipe.
And following this period
of so much--
this is the golden age--
"Drinks" from Straub is 1916,
"The ABCs of Mixing Cocktails"
I've actually snuck in English;
book is around 1915.
It was republished all the
way through the '20s.
"Drinks And How They're Mixed
and Served" by Paul Lowe was
1904, but was published
for a decade.
And Applegreen's
is around 1916.
So between 1862 and 1916 so many
recipes were created and
the guests were so familiar with
them, that the bartenders
needed these little sort of
cheat sheet books to put in
their vest pocket.
So this would be one of the
sizes of the books, and they
would put them in their
vest pocket.
And someone came to order a
drink, and they didn't know
what it was, they probably did
what most of us do now-- they
sort of go over here and they
started looking through it.
So it's sort of a medieval form
of Google from a hundred
years ago, and it's
interesting.
It's also interesting what I
saw as I was putting this
together for you.
And this is why I took these
photos is if you look at the
trim sizes of all these books,
they're very similar.
This is taken from above,
they're all very similar size.
These are very similar
in size, almost
the same trim size.
Moving forward, now we have this
genre of books that are
sort of vest pocket books that
come out together all around
the same 15 years.
And then we move to what I'm
calling "the end of the era".
This is a book I've also
brought to give away.
1917, Hugo Ensslin's "Recipes
for Mixed Drinks." It's
strange, you would think that
the sort of last cocktail book
to come out before the golden
age ended and prohibition was
enacted would be like a plush
Bible that came with, who
knows what, a special box,
but it's a very--
it looks like a very--
simple book.
But this book by Ensslin, who
was also a New York bartender,
there are at least 50 of his
recipes in a book that came
out later, which will be in one
of my next slides, "The
Savoy Cocktail Book."
And what's interesting, if you
look at Ensslin, 1917, versus
some of the books of the late
1800s, is the sophistication
of the cocktails by 1917
verses the 1860s.
This is a time in America
where champagne was--
champagne was around in the
early 1800s, but imagine what
champagne tasted like after it
sat on a horse drawn cart
crossing the West till it got to
the guys digging for gold.
I mean, it probably didn't
have much effervescence.
Who knows how sweet it
was to preserve it?
So this is by 1917, especially
in New York and on the East
Coast, you have all these
interesting European
ingredients from all over the
world, and all of them were
going into the cocktails.
And the cocktails of this that
are in this book and they come
from this era are some of the
most sophisticated that have
ever been created.
But as I said, it's the
end of the era.
One of the popular myths is
that prohibition was this
great time to drink in America,
and it wasn't.
When prohibition was enacted,
there was about a year, year
and a half for people who
had a lot of money
to stock their cellar.
And some of them who really did
have a lot of money put as
much as they possibly
could in there.
But for most people, they
couldn't afford to save up for
the end of the world.
So as they ran out of booze,
and then pretty soon you're
either buying booze from
gangsters or you're buying
booze from someone who's bring
it illegally off of a clipper.
A lot of these people who were
selling the booze were
criminals in it of themselves,
they could not be trusted.
They were adulterating a lot of
the spirits, cutting them.
You certainly weren't mixing
with some of these finer
cordials and liqueurs, and
bitters that you could get
when booze was still legal.
And drinking was illegal, so you
had to do it quietly, you
had to do it discreetly.
And the great bartenders of the
golden age from 1890 to
1916 they either quick
bartending or they left.
They went to Cuba, they went
to Tijuana, they went to
Paris, they went to London.
They went somewhere else, where
their skills could be
used, they could
work in hotels.
And what we saw happen during
this time, which is
interesting, is these sort of
prohibition era guides.
Here's how "Noble Experiments",
there's another
one called "Giggle Water." And
the pub dates, the pub dates
for these books are--
"Here's How" is 1927--
so that's on 1919 and 1933
roughly is prohibition--
so that's towards the end .
"Noble Experiments" is 1930,
"Giggle Watter" is 1928.
So this is people, whose stash
has run dry, there's recipes
for how to compound different
spirits in there.
The recipes have gone from
these very sort of
sophisticated cocktails from
Ensslin to sort of going more
towards the Screwdriver, or
more towards the Bronx.
This is a period--
and the other thing you'll
notice about the trim size,
you can't tell by this, but
the "here's how" books are
also really small.
And this is a period, where
books go from being books
written by bartenders for
bartenders to books written by
who knows who-- because they
don't want to put their name
on it, because it's
prohibition--
for people, who are basically
hosting these illegal parties,
going to speakeasies,
and want to know a
little more about it.
And the content has really left
the realm, the cocktail
guide has really left the realm
of the bartender and has
moved into the realm of the
amateur or the host.
Moving forward from here what,
as I said before, these great
bartenders in New York, or in
San Francisco, or in Chicago
and New Orleans, in Cincinnati,
who wanted to
continue their trade left and
they move on. "The Cafe Royal
Cocktail Book", 1937,
is from London.
The 1930 "The Savoy Cocktail
Book" on the right, which is
still in print, and the one in
the middle, "The Artistry of
Mixing Drinks" by Frank Meier,
around 1937 as well.
These are the house cocktail
books of three amazing bars.
"The Cafe Royal" and "The Savoy"
were sort of UKBG--
the United Kingdom
Bartender Guild.
These were sort of their house
bibles in many ways, their
sort of Jerry Thomases.
And what happened thankfully for
the cocktail globally is
that a lot of the best drinks,
drinks like you saw in
Ensslin, move right
over to Europe.
And these are--
I have a couple of these--
I think I have one of these
somewhere to give you guys--
but these books are amazing.
And this is when you really see
the books go from being
Jerry Thomas' "Bartender's
Guide" to being books about
the places that drinks
came from.
Moving forward, post
prohibition, in my opinion,
things start tapering off,
they get kind of sad.
"The Stork Club Cocktail Book",
1946, "The Old Waldorf
Bar Book", 1935, and Crosby
Gaige's "Cocktail Guide And
Ladies' Companion"
in the middle.
I think Crosby Gaige might
have been gay.
But these are books, they were
written by journalists after
prohibition.
And it's interesting, as I said
before, we've gone from
sort of the bar manual being
always authored by bartenders
to the bar manual through
prohibition and all these sort
of nifty little gifty guides,
being something that is now
not written by bartenders
anymore.
They're written by hosts,
they're written by men or
women among town.
And they are written not for
bartenders to make good drinks
in bars, but they're written
for the host to sort of
continue their roaring
'20s parties into
the '30s and '40s.
The thing that you will find,
and then moving forward, "The
Didactic Bartender", 1934, "The
Official Mixer's Manual"
by Patrick Gavin Duffy and
1945-51 Townsend's
"Bartender's Book." This is when
these kind of crotchety
bartenders who had been part of
the golden age and ridden
out through prohibition, they
see what's going on and
they're disgusted.
And what these books that you'll
find from 1934 to 1955
are written with the bartenders
are basically
telling the young bartenders
about how they used to walk
through the snow, and how long
it took to get to school; and
then they want them to stop
making drinks with orange
juice and drinks with cream,
they want them to go back to
the classics.
They want them to learn the
classics first and then they
can move forward.
But it's almost like the
bartender has lost the ability
to command an audience
anymore.
People are not as interested
in cocktails
as they were before.
America does not have
the same spirits.
We're in the middle
of two world wars.
People are drinking what they're
drinking to get drunk.
They're not drinking because
the economy and because the
country is on the up and up.
So I call these "the didactic
bartender guides."
And then we move forward to--
I know, this is going to
end, guys, hold on--
cocktail theory.
The first cocktail theory book
"The Fine Art of Mixing
Drinks" by David Embury, was not
written by a bartender, it
was written by a lawyer.
It's about 700 pages, incredibly
dry and acerbic.
David Embury liked his cocktail
with a lot of booze,
a little bit of sour,
and almost no sugar.
And this is where we move into
the Mad Men era, hard-drinking
men, in the seven-to-one
Martini.
Who knows where the
bartender is.
And I included a book that came
out in 2003, "The Joy of
Mixology", because this is the
second theoretical bar book.
And then we move,
essentially--
I'm not sure how many people
you've heard talk about the
history of the cocktail--
but the cocktail really pretty
much goes into the
toilet by the 1950s.
It's highballs, it's
old fashions.
I think that maybe the Patrick
Gavin Duffys of the
world got their day.
And the drinks, they're
not very interesting.
They're dry, they're strong,
they get the ad men through.
Once again, we're at war.
And then pretty much, if you
want to find anything about
cocktails, you've got to look
at books like "The Complete
Book of Drink" by
T.E. Carling, or
these Grossman's guides.
And the cocktail book has
taken away from the bon
vivance and taken away from the
sort of "gay happy hosts",
and move towards the English.
And things become very
analytical and dry.
And then we move forward to the
absolute darkest point of
the cocktail--
the 1970s.
There's two cocktail
books that I'd
recommend from the 1970s.
One is Stan Jones' "Complete
Bar Guide" from 1977.
And I've put another book here
from 2010 "Diffordsguide",
which I do recommend.
I recommend both these books.
And once again, I want you to
look at these books sitting
right next to each other,
because these books are very
much those kitchen sink time
books that have thousands of
recipes in them.
And they both actually have
around the same trim size.
As we're going through all the
possible genres of cocktail
books, that I could possibly
think of writing, when I'm
thinking, what should I write,
if I write a cocktail book?
The autobiography is
actually an option.
In the 1950s, Johnny Brooks
wrote "My 35 Years Behind
Bars." He claims that he created
the Between the Sheets
cocktail, a beguiling mixture
of gin and lemon, and brandy
and Cuantro.
Also very dry, something that
could certainly get someone
who wasn't paying attention to
what they're drinking between
the sheets.
And then a book by my friend
Toby Checchini "Cosmopolitan".
Toby wrote this book in 2003.
And I consider it to very much
be the sort of kitchen
confidential of the
bartending world.
Anthony Bourdain wrote this
great book about being a chef
that basically involves nothing
but parties and drugs,
m girls in the walk-in.
And that's sort of Toby's
basically follow-up to that.
I'm sad to inform many of you
who are thinking of leaving
your excellent job at Google,
but that is not the way
bartending really is.
And then we--
we're getting there, guys--
we move to what I'm calling
"the modern giants".
These are my modern follow-up
100 years later from those
celebrity cocktail books.
You have "Cocktail Technique" on
your left, written by Kazuo
Uyeda, the founder of the
hardshake method.
The hardshake method for all
of you cocktail geeks-- you
probably know about this, but
for those of you who don't--
it's a method of shaking, using
a cobbler shaker, that
has become very popular
among the YouTube set.
If you go to a bar and you see
someone shaking like this, and
they look very Japanese, they've
probably been watching
Kazuo Uyeda do this three-point
method shake.
Greg Boehm has actually
translated this
book, and it's excellent.
You have "The Craft of the
Cocktail" in the middle, Dale
DeGroff, the sort of Yoda and
tree trunk of American
cocktails, wrote that in 2002.
I have Charles Schumann's
"American Bar".
Ironically, Charles Schumann
is from Munich.
He has a bar, called Schumann's,
which has been
around for at least 25 years.
He's one of the most elegant,
charismatic, and interesting
bartenders on earth.
And his book "American Bar",
written by a German, was a
huge influence on my book.
And then down below there you
have the "Cocktails of the
Ritz Paris", written by Colin
Field, an Englishman, who has
been bartending at the Ritz in
Paris, which is now closed for
a couple years, for
over 20 years.
So we have the modern giants
in the cocktail technique.
We have a book that is very
much one of those Harry
Johnson "Hoffman House" books.
It's very technical, very
informative, as far as what
he's thinking when he
makes a cocktail.
We have "The Cocktails of the
Ritz Paris", which is sort of
a reprise of "The House Cocktail
Book." In "American
Bar", we have a little bit of
everything, which is what I
ended up going for.
And in "Craft of the Cocktail",
we have a coffee
table book filled with great
recipes and photographs.
And in my opinion, if you read
"Craft" closely, you'll see a
bit of that sort of Patrick
Gavin Duffy, sort of "let's
bring it back, guys".
And moving forward we have this
whole genre now of what
Dave Wondrich calls
"mixography".
And this is, guys, once again,
going back to the 1940s.
These are guys that know way
too much, they have way too
many college degrees.
And instead of studying whatever
you do to get PhDs,
they decide, I'll write
a cocktail book.
So in the 1980s, I
believe, Lowell
Edmunds wrote "Martini".
He is a classics professor,
I believe, somewhere in a
college in New Jersey.
In 2004-05, forgive me, Dave,
Dave Wondrich wrote "Imbibe".
Dave Wondrich also has a Ph.D.
In early English literature, I
believe, in Comp. lit.
William Grimes, "Straight
Up or on the Rocks".
I think he wrote that in 1993.
I remember reading
that as a college
bartender in Madison, Wisconsin.
At this time I was serving
cocktails and orange juice
from the soda gun, a lot
of Alabama Slammers,
Long Island Iced Teas.
My idea with molecular mythology
was a cement mixer,
which is Bailey's with a little
bit of Rose's lime--
stick a straw in it--
snake bites, the whole
nine yards.
And I remember reading that book
when I was in college,
and being like, this is so
boring, who would want to
drink in a hotel bar?
It's actually a pretty
good book.
2005 or 2006, Ted Haigh, set
designer, who actually has
done the set design for
the latest series
of "Boardwalk Empire".
Ted's based out of LA.
This book is brilliant,
well illustrated.
It's called "Vintage Spirits and
Forgotten Cocktails", and
it's really one of the books
that is most responsible for
the return of lot of these old
sort of weird spirits they go
in cocktails that come out
of books like this.
And on the bottom "The Grog
Log", an early '90s book by
tiki guru named Jeff Berry,
who has spent the last 20
years trying to find out what
people like Trader Vic and Don
Beach were putting in these
very potent and delicious
cocktails that ruled
the '40s and '50s.
Last--
almost, guys, we're
getting there--
the coffee table book.
This is "Speakeasy" by Jay and
Dusham of Employees Only.
Certainly, there have been a
number of others that I could
have put up here.
But what I've found in the last
ten years, as I said,
thinking about what I'm going
to write my cocktail book
about, is that the people buying
bartender books from
the publishers, were used to
buying books from chefs.
And they were used to not
writing professional bar
guides, they were used to
writing books that were sort
of something you could-- it had
a Manhattan and a Martini,
and a Margarita, and was sort
of light and lively, and
something that you could put
on your coffee table.
This is a great book, but it
wasn't what I wanted to write.
Another book that I've actually
edited for the last
1, 2, 3,4, 5, 6 7 years is "The
Food and Wine Cocktail
Book." When I started working on
this book, after Rob Willie
left, it was just a kind of
collection of all sorts of old
cocktail books.
And what I found in 2005-2006,
when I started, there was this
sort of-- as I said before, I
started working at the Pegu
Club in 2005.
And I felt like what was going
on all over the country was
absolutely unlike anything
that had gone
in the history before.
And I found for the last seven
years that I can use this book
with my editor Kate Krader and
the editors of Food and Wine
to actually document what's
going on year after year.
So our latest edition
just came out.
The other ones are around.
And it's kind of a neat way to
follow what is out there.
And then last--
actually not even last,
but not least--
is the "PDT Cocktail Book", a
book I wrote in 2011, a book
some of you, guys, probably have
in your hand, and maybe
even pacing through it.
What I wanted to do when
I wrote this book--
and I promise I'm going to open
this up for some dialogue
in one second--
is write a book that brought
back the 1930s book, brought
back illustrations instead
of photos.
I wanted a book that didn't
just have recipes, but had
recipes that had a story.
I feel like cocktails tell a
story, and I wanted the drinks
in this book to tell a story.
For that reason the
illustrations in the book
aren't illustrations of me
making cocktails at PDT, but
they're illustrations that
document maybe the playfulness
of the cocktail.
I wanted a book that had an
annotated bibliography, that
not only showed you where I
found these recipes, but where
you can look for more.
I wanted a book that had
the food recipes in the
back, and on and on.
There's one more cocktail book
that I want to show you, one
more format of cocktail book
I want to show you before I
start opening things up
for conversation.
If you guys could
play the video.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
-The best bartenders in the
world realize that there's a
sense of nobility to
serving people.
-So this is some of the
different ice that we use here
at Little Branch.
We use a hand-cut enormous
rock of ice.
When you have a drink sitting
on that, it will dilute much
more slowly, so you can sit
there and sip your drink,
without it turning into
a watery mess.
-If you have lime juice, or if
you have eggs, or if you have
cream, and it's already a cloudy
drink, that's usually
the decision maker between
whether we stir or shake.
-And the fun part, we're going
to give it an orange twist.
And in this case, a flamed
orange twist.
You always want to use
a nice fresh orange
with a shiny skin.
-Sea salt tends to clump around
the edge of the glass,
whereas kosher salt gives
you this nice fine rim.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
-This is the Irish Coffee.
You can use the coffee of your
choice, two brown sugar cubes,
and just give them a crush.
Irish whiskey is the
traditional.
A little bit of hot water,
and just float it
on top, mint leaf.
And that is an Irish Coffee.
-Caipirinha.
-Tom Collins.
-Daiquiri.
-Sazerac.
-The Mojito.
-Gin & Tonic.
-Pisco Sour.
[END OF VIDEO PLAYBACK]
JIM MEEHAN: This is an app that
I did right after I was
working on the "PDT Cocktail
Book." It came out right
before the "PDT Cocktail Book"
came out, so I couldn't really
do much to promote it.
But it's a book that
is all digital.
And it's so hard to explain to
someone how to stir a drink,
but when you have a video of it,
it's completely different.
It's a new format of
cocktail book.
And I guess what I'll leave
you with before I take a
couple questions, because I know
we're running late, is
the future of cocktail books,
I think, is going to depend
heavily on the technology that
you guys are working on, on
the way that we search for
everything, and how we display
information.
I would argue that
it's so much--
I prefer, for instance, having
something that I can hand
someone, something that I can
touch, something that I can
refer to it.
And when I wrote this book, I
didn't think bartenders would
still keep it behind the bar.
I figured that everything
was moving towards apps.
And thankfully, that
hasn't happened.
But I would argue to all of you
that there's really never
been a better time to drink.
The information out there--
especially after the seminar--
and knowing that, and knowing
that there's so much
information out there, and that
this information is being
accessed by people all the
world, it's kind of up to you,
guys, for how they'll use it.
And I guess the question I have
is, as I talked about in
the beginning, walking you
through the journey that I
went on, looking through all
these old cocktail books.
Before I weighed in what was
good about them, or what I
didn't like about them, and
decided what I wanted to
write, when I wrote
my own book.
How can the search that we use
on a daily basis, many, many
times a day, maybe evolve or
change so that you can see a
little bit of how you find
information, instead of just
getting to that information.
So I'll leave that
to you guys.
No pressure.
Do you guys have
many questions?
Complaints?
[APPLAUSE]
JIM MEEHAN: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: We've got a
question over there.
JIM MEEHAN: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
that I had in mind [INAUDIBLE],
but for
everything that's come out
in 2013 and end of 2012.
What do you see as
sticking around?
What do you see as going to
be passe in a year or so?
JIM MEEHAN: I think that, what's
interesting is we live
in New York.
So what's happening here will
come and go quickly, because
our interest cycle here is--
one of the things I realized
working with the New York
media is that really all they
write about, God bless them
is-- what's new and
what's hot.
So if you want to remain in the
media and become popular,
you have to constantly evolve.
So it's hard to say in the
bigger picture how long some
of these things will
stay around.
I think, at the end
of the day, people
buy with their eyes.
And also people are impatient.
So the beautiful things, the
things that involve the
ceremony, the things that create
cocktails, where a
guest watches the bartender make
the drink, and then the
glass goes to the guest, and
then everyone looks at that
guest and says, I want that.
And then the guest actually
likes that drink.
Those will be the things
that stay around.
I think that the reason why
people go out for drinks,
instead of making them for
themselves in their home, is
because they want to
see and be seen.
Even if they want to
do it discretely.
So I think that if you apply
that logic to some of the
trends that are going on.
If it's delicious, if it allows
you to see and be seen,
if it's efficient, I think
it'll stay around.
CREW MEMBER: Please use the
microphones for your questions
because we are recording.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
All right.
My question is, I guess I feel
like, when I was a kid, I
couldn't walk in a grocery store
and find an avocado.
I'd probably had never
even seen one.
So as the world's become much
more global, and we have
access to all different things
from all around the world, how
has that changed the kind of
drinks that people are, I
guess, experimenting with or
designing, or whatever--
JIM MEEHAN: Yeah, I mean I
think that it depends on
where you're at.
For instance, in San Francisco,
the mentality about
what ingredients they work with
is different than the
mentality, say, that we
work with in New York.
New York is as close to Europe
as we are to San Francisco.
So I find that, depending on
which part of the world you're
in, you'll see different
trends for how they use
ingredients.
For instance, in Copenhagen with
Noman, the sort of new
Nordic cuisine, you'll see a
different more locavore sense,
whereas in New York or in
London, you'll probably see
more of interchangeable global
sense; San Fransisco--
more local and sustainable.
But I think that in general, as
I said before, it's making
drinks I think more
interesting.
And one of the reasons why I've
been able to remain as
interested as I am in cocktails,
is because
cocktails have like an
anthropology to them.
So you can follow the of this
is agave-based, so I'm going
to use an agave-based
sweetener.
And jabanero peppers are sort of
things you find in Mexico.
So it's sort of the more you
look at it, I think, the more
interesting it becomes.
I had a reporter recently come
to me at a charity event a
couple nights ago and said,
so what are the
latest trends in cocktails?
What a lot of people around here
are saying is that we're
going back to the basics,
more simple cocktails.
And one of the secret I'll tell
you about most bartenders
is most of them are
pretty lazy.
So, of course, there is an
incentive to keep it simple.
But I think that the more you
see avocados in cocktails, the
more you see these sort of
interesting and esoteric
cocktails, that maybe involve
things that you didn't expect
or never desired to be in your
drinks, it's what makes going
out to drink interesting
to me.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: So, first
of all, PDT was my
first Speakeasy, so--
JIM MEEHAN: We never meant
to be a Speakeasy,
but I'll take that.
AUDIENCE: Sorry.
but going through the phone
booth, and doing that whole
kind of thing was a really
awesome introduction.
So thank you for that.
JIM MEEHAN: No, thank you.
AUDIENCE: So one thing I want
to ask is so the next time I
go, what should I get in terms
of cocktail plus deep fried
hot dog pairing?
And a follow-up, how
do I get in?
JIM MEEHAN: I do have a limited
amount of business
cards, which you could probably
auction off after
some of you go to
your meetings.
But, yeah, I think the way that
the menu is set up at
PDT, is I came from a wine
background before I focused on
cocktails, so the list goes
from light, refreshing,
usually white spirit drinks,
moving onto to sours, moving
onto stirred and strong drinks,
sometimes rich drinks
in the winter.
So the idea is to drink
through it.
The idea of what we're
doing trying to
do is course cocktails.
So in an ideal situation, like
an ideal PDT experience for me
is you start out with something
light an dry,
something like a Paddington,
which is a sort of Daiquiri
variation with Marmalade
and absinth.
You move into something that's
maybe a touch stronger, a
touch sweeter, maybe a
touch more bitter.
And then you finish off with
something brown and stirred,
like the Benton's
Old Fashioned.
She'll send the kids
to college.
As far as the food, one of the
things people always say, so
what hot dog should I have
with what cocktail?
And really the food is there, if
you have too many of these
cocktails, you're going
to have to stop
having these cocktails.
So the food is really there to
sustain you and fortify you as
you sip your way through
my menu.
We have the Chang dog with the
kimchi, so as long as you're
not on a date, I highly
recommend that.
The Torres tots, I recommend
everyone gets that.
That's Sue Torres from Suenos,
all these amazing Mexican
ingredients on top.
Well, we have the mission
Chinese dog, which has a
little bit of Sichuan pepper,
so it's a little numbing, as
long as that doesn't
bother you.
And then we have the wily dog,
which is, as I've said on the
menu, this from wd~50,
the dogs go
molecular before the drinks.
So they're all there to please
you and help you gain weight,
and keep you drinking.
So it's your choice.
And what I told--
AUDIENCE: Is that what the
deep-fried mayo is for?
JIM MEEHAN: Deep-fried
mayo is to keep you
large, living large.
But what I tell my
staff is that
ideally we want to serve--
we spend so much time keeping
this menu up-to-date--
that we want to serve you
the drinks on this menu.
A lot of times cocktail geeks
will go to a bar and they be
like, so what can I
get off the menu?
And it's just like, what we're
trying to do, what we spend
all of our time on this menu.
So we do want you to try
the drinks on the menu.
If none of them sound
appetizing, we generally defer
to old PDT cocktails
or the classics.
So I mean that's sort
of our procedure.
You could walk in, just like you
do at Milk&Honey and say,
I want something brown
and stirred.
I want something with tequila.
I love the Diablo, or whatever
your favorite drink is, and
then they should be able to
help you with that too.
So I think what we'll do for
those of you that can possibly
stay longer or drink more is I
will find one of the-- we'll
reposition one of these tables
for those of you who bought a
book and want me to
sign it still.
And you get a shot of Mezcal as
soon as I sign your book.
How do you feel about that?
Sound good?
[APPLAUSE]
JIM MEEHAN: Thank you,
guys, very much.
I really appreciate your time.
CREW MEMBER: Thank
you, Jim Meehan.